[Music]
we're sailing towards an iceberg little
white peak in the distance getting
closer and closer but really it's been
underneath us the whole time it's
nothing worse than a kid we have some
bad news on the case the print we lifted
from the victim it's from your son
there's got to be an explanation they go
to the same school Jacobs in his class
yes we know that Lin have you arrested
my son before we begin I want to make
something clear a kid your age charged
with first-degree murder is tried as an
adult I swear I didn't tell me
we believe you you have admitted to
being in the park and a fellow student
alleges you had a knife she would bring
to school I guess they're saying he
looks smug and remorseless this is gonna
follow him around for the rest of his
life it's a mistake I'm gonna figure it
out
chief any doubts about Jacobs honest no
of course not
where is the knife now
so you've been lying to me I did what
any parent would have done you mean his
fader to the courtroom
my only job now is trying to protect her
some recruiters in our own home
acting like verdoorn we are know oh my
god do you think this is normal
you gotta get answers for ourselves I
know what you did
lawyers have boundaries I don't anymore
remember that in their eyes it isn't
just Jacob his guilty
you all are did you follow me here he's
damaging this is evidence you're scaring
him good you should be scared I'm scared
so I have to know I want the truth
you can be a good man or you can be a
good father it was not normal to go back
- it was just before and after
you